es ist einer der spektakulärsten
raubzüge der vergangenen jahre die täter
brachen in das weltberühmte grüne
gewölbe in dresden ein zerschlugen mit
einer axt die glasvitrine die
glasscheiben einer vitrine und
schleppten teile drei jubiläen
garnituren aus dem sächsischen
staatsschatz es handelt sich um stücke
der brilliant color garnitur von august
dem starken
der diamant rosen garnituren sowie
perlenschmuck die kunstschätze stammen
aus dem 18 jahrhundert und sind ein
kulturerbe von unermesslichem wert
monatelang gab es keine spur nur immer
wieder neue ideen wer die täter sein
könnten jetzt aber die überraschung es
gibt konkrete hinweise
es war der größte kunstraub in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik der
juwelenraub im berühmten dresdner grünen
gewölbe am morgen des 25
november 2009 10 brechen räuber in das
historische museumsgebäude 1
sie stehen aus einer vitrine wertvolle
diamanten und brillanten der
sicherheitsdienst ist die ganze zeit im
gebäude der einbruch wird registriert
die polizei verständigt die braucht dann
fünf minuten um eine streife zu
alarmieren
doch es ist bereits zu spät die täter
sind weg es gibt nur noch aufnahmen der
überwachungskamera und später das
phantombild eines der räuber in
verschiedenen möglichen versionen jetzt
gut ein dreiviertel jahr später gibt es
eine große razzia in berlin führt eine
spur ins clan milieu die ermittler haben
einen mann gefunden der in
berlin-neukölln fingierte handy sim
karten vertreibt solche karten sollen
von den tätern zu absprachen vor und
während des einbruchs genutzt worden
sein
eine heiße spur die ermittler erhoffen
sich darüber die täter identifizieren zu
können
vor dem grünen gewölbe steht jetzt bild
reporter michael deutschmann
gestern gab es also die razzia was genau
wurde dabei gesucht da offensichtlich
hat die staatsanwalt der erkenntnis über
ein mann der mit sim karten handelt und
diese sind karten über einen
internetshop ein internetcafé in der
berliner hermannstraße vertrieben hat an
regierte adressen also an erfundene
person und diese erfundene personen das
haben die ermittler der soko collette
hier in dresden herausbekommen
diese erfundene person dahinter
verbargen sich also die täter die ihr am
25 november das grüne gewölbe ausgeraubt
haben
interessant dabei die ermittler sind den
tipp dann hier auf die spur gekommen
durch eine so genannte funkzellenabfrage
nhs um 4 kurz nach 4 uhr stattgefunden
drews da sind relativ wenig leute
unterwegs in diesem areal natürlich und
dann konnte man genau gucken welche
handys waren eingebucht wo ist sowas
jetzt mobilfunk gespräche geführt worden
und so ist man dann nach unseren
informationen den tier dann auf die spur
gekommen
hat diese hat diese sim karten orten
können und jetzt geht es darum
herauszubekommen wer verbirgt sich
hinter diesen sogenannten regierten
personen die man vermutet
muss ja sein die hoffnung war nicht mehr
so groß dass man die ganzen juwelen
wiederfindet weil sie vielleicht schon
längst zerstört worden sind weiter
verkauft worden sind steigt jetzt die
hoffnung dass man diesen kunstschatz
doch zurückbekommt die informationen
dass der schatz noch nicht zerstört ist
die verdichten sich stück bestücken wir
haben hier in dresden im juli schon
darüber berichten können eine
information dass die spur ins claudio
ins berliner clown mücke immer heißer
wird damals gab es informationen dass
die ermittler angeblich teile des
schatzes sogar relativ klar geortet
hätten
das hat uns hier ein informant gesagt
die ermittler selber und auch
staatsanwaltschaft geben sich da sehr
bedeckt und je schweigsamer die werden
erfahrungsgemäß umso heißer werden die
spuren muss mal sehen was diese razzia
jetzt in berlin
für ergebnisse bringt wie das die ganzen
ermittlungen weiter bringt wir sind alle
sehr gespannt die staatsanwaltschaft
hier gibt kaum details preis wenn man
fragt handelt sich um arabische clans
handelt es sich um andere kriminelle
heißt es dazu können wir nichts sagen
nur so viel die spur ist heiß vielen
dank michael deutschland live aus
dresden
dankeschön